bonsoir jodie foster ce soir vous
recevez une palme d'or d'honneur pour
l'ensemble de votre carrière
je n'ai jamais c'est vrai le festival de
cannes il a une place à part je suppose
dans votre coeur je rappelle que vous
avez monté les marches pour la première
fois on est très jeune pour taxi driver
un jeune on a gagné la palme d'or
d'ailleurs et c'était en fait c'était le
début de ma carrière en fait enfin
j'avais déjà fait les films quand même
oui où les vilains by his en décroisant
et mais c'était vraiment le début de
quelque chose et de pouvoir venir ici de
parler français
pour moi cette étape vous sonnez dans
quel état d'esprit vous étiez à ce
moment là on voit ses angoisses et en
basse et je pense que oui c'était un peu
trop pour moi je savais pas trop quoi
penser
et ce soir vous êtes plus détendus ce
soit ça va mieux ça va mieux j'ai des
amis qui sont la gestion avec ma femme
j'ai des amis sur les jurys par exemple
ou alors quand même c'est comme andy
c'est comme retourner la famille vous
avez enlacés spike lee vous avez joué
récemment aux côtés de tahar rahim 7 en
famille en fait voilà voilà oui il ya
enfin ça c'est une très belle expérience
à travers tarrare c'est quelqu'un avec
énormément de talent j'étais
très contente de travailler désigné
coupable je rappelle le nom du film the
mauritanie accusations sur la tombe
oui le 14 les merci beaucoup de jeudi
soir et même soirée